oh dude you would have been so upset
today why
Papa's on the trail like you always is
yeah I'm tariff rate back in my home
turf drove to San Diego yesterday that's
my home turf going and I'm I mean I'm 20
miles out from my house so it's I mean
it's rattlesnake territory yeah and I
might I listen to music I ride my bike
and I see a couple on horses up on
horses right big horses yeah I was like
cut my attention I can see she's going
like this at me yelling yeah and I'm
like oh maybe they need help or maybe
there maybe there's a giant rattlesnake
up things so you'll excuse me and this
lady goes where the [ __ ] is your mask
where the [ __ ] is your [ __ ] mask
pride and pride about art about my age
almost at our age I did my sorry my both
about my age maybe a little younger she
was where the [ __ ] your math oh [ __ ]
is your mag oh excuse me she goes where
the [ __ ] is your math you're risking you
everybody out here I go who's out here
who's out here
she was where's your master yo why in
the world I'm trying not to test that
situation I go why in the world would I
wear masks out here are you after your
goddamn mine yelling at me she was well
where's your [ __ ] nacio who are you
talking to saying where's your [ __ ]
[ __ ] mask and then and then I'm like
you should how would I beat the [ __ ]
bond will hold on the hold on and their
boyfriend goes yeah dude it's not cool I
like what you say it's not cool I go
what's not cool and now they don't have
masks on
they have bandanas on and I go oh you
dumb dumbs think the bandanas help you
you think about dancing and as I say
this the blurred upstairs go let's do a
breeze so we can feel stupid they are
breeze comes the things blow up by yo oh
wow I can see your entire face and see
your entire face you think that's
helping I see you know you guys should
do you should wait because there's I
pass a few uh
bike lists on the way you should none of
them are wearing masks because we're not
morons so when they come you guys should
ruin your whole day and wait here like
it's your job because nobody's paying
you
Faiers not paying to do this you guys
should wait here and then yell at the
other guys coming and as there's tell me
some the two guys who has passed in I
was talking when we get to the top they
come by and she goes when where's your
mask and they just start laughing and
keep riding by I said I should have done
that but I I thought you were I thought
you were worn by a snake and I stopped
and spanked complete with my time and
then the boyfriend says something goes
yeah well we're on here tomorrow you
better wear a mask I was like holy [ __ ]
I mean you're serious dude you better
wear masks are yo dude I'm on this trail
every day I'll be back here tomorrow 9
a.m. I might right [ __ ] naked just a
prove a point I go and how about where's
the math for your horses you know oh you
don't care about animals oh my god you
know you know your horse can get it she
was not [ __ ] cares it's the stupid
say ah you didn't know horses can get it
and they can have you looked it up or
she can get it bring that up J like you
don't know who are skinny like all all
and I go Papa you guys watch CNN you
watching cm your skier straight this is
the first time leaving the house this
first time leaving the house you guys
have no idea nobody where masta for you
[ __ ] morons now you got my bike and
rode off that's great how about the guy
goes you better have a mask on tomorrow
you better have a mask on a lot Wow
that's that would cause a big problem
for me and your outside oh dude um and
I'm I'm on to pay mountains I'm over the
hill where it's like there's nothing
yeah
I'm not gonna wear masks in here this
this whole thing is divided people what
do it's crazy me I could tell the the
boyfriend it wasn't such a [ __ ] was
down to fight over it
he was down a fight I could tell they
would escalate there what do you wait
you better have mascara ah you know
decent-size guy just went ah you're
serious
well dude I'll be I'm here every day up
here Martin I want I'll be endlessly
please I know my family's choked my
conscience and spanked him for me I know
if he if he comes out you please
double leg him and then just just tie
him up just put your legs and they're
just they're just palisade rich kids
first under the house writing daddy's
horses well also oh it's also
ever been perfect I'd say at
Birkenstocks on hey you're on the trail
real riders we're bringing it first time
on the house I like first on the house
and then you don't care about your
animals and that set them on fire and I
said you don't care about your animals
Sam on fire well you didn't know horses
can get it there's been a case of me I
don't know if he died but a horse get
contract open 19 oh you don't care about
your horses as he stress man you know of
course his eyes are like looking in for
when he's stressed man he's off [ __ ]
[ __ ] you George's oh yeah that's horse
it's a horse's better be able to fight
man well I found this article the horses
can spread it to each other
he's on the ass and the horses yeah you
got a little fiery secular horse up yeah
just pull him off it's like getting back
in those Birkenstocks Oh God any crazy
oh you tell the guy was dead it it's
Escalade there well this is he kind of
tough for no no no that he's in [ __ ]
peanuts jockeys like I did on but you
look kind of you look a little bit silly
and maybe a little
you look like yeah and you're in your
bike helmet in Europe you just look like
a giant guy on a bike huh it's not a
very flattering look oh it's just a bad
idea you thought I he could give you a
little shove around because you're in
the money no you know what happens this
what happens when you when you get
together with a [ __ ] and she's gonna get
you in trouble if that's the prior
when you're with a Osho gay we're not a
rich [ __ ] I'm saying I can't do anything
hurt I forget you and I can kill you and
the horses though pretty fast yeah I you
know I'm gonna do with the horses
there's stupid nose is peach those and a
whole them hell yeah and Dan is that
right for two so you put your fingers in
their nostrils and you hold I look at
him I go hey bro
yes sweet mask now watch this you take
the words new girl and you break his
neck nope just two fingers knuckle deep
in his nose and I drop them to the
ground and I go hey hey cotton she was
high o Conte and I line all throughout
and I piss on them
Oh get your camera out my pee on them
yeah and I like camera go there's your
mask it's pretty aggressive
there's your mask yeah and that crazy
though
well yeah that the yeah societies
divided into two
hypocrite you gotta carry murder Hornets
and release them in their faces look
like bullets I just [ __ ] them here's
your bend him over the rock and [ __ ]
them and took his math well that's that
would be that's my friend who's tough
guy and how about I bend you over this
rock and [ __ ] you in the ass that could
happen are you gonna fight a 54 year old
because ya know I said I'm gonna [ __ ]
yeah I am dude you about to get [ __ ]
with a guy in the ebike in spandex but I
think what you should do is you should
say you should go hey I'll give you a
shove around that's what you should say
just say something weird don't worry
probably man well I thought I was
deescalate by making other [ __ ] they
were not that's when they really sound
like bad people thats why it really got
spicy but they sound like bad people you
have a long day they're gonna have a
long day cuz there's a bunch of bikers a
bunch of hikers no masks ya know why
Brian yeah well we're outside we're
outside yeah it's gonna be fine now
where's your mask
yeah the governor told your dumb ass to
wear a mask and you're gonna do it and
you're gonna do it why that's why I am
well let's start with if you're gonna do
that outlaw the other things that kill
people anyway
anyway that's a tough one it's cut
Friday apparently it's not it's no
longer cute Friday it's [ __ ] Fridays
come Friday and I hope they're back
there tomorrow I kind of want to come
with you and I'm not joking
no I just I don't want to can you
imagine
do you imagine saying that somebody
yelling me where the [ __ ] is your math
what are we gonna do do fight fight why
just bring super-soakers assume the face
just resist that's a good day
I think u s-- laugh at them I guess by
the best thing ended I mean that's a
good idea have a good day and then uh
yeah don't catch anthrax from your horse
I don't know more likely to die bein bit
by the round it's going to be is it the
larger question is that everybody seems
to be getting their information from
depending on the sources you listen to I
can tell where you stand politically
right it's it's just the way we are as
human beings I think that most of us
have feelings we have a feeling and then
we go we go
and we'll we'll go and get a source of
information that compounds that support
you can find online whatever it's hard
not to be that way as a human being it's
hard not to do that it's called bias
confirmation confirmation bias and with
this all right you're gonna put whatever
you want yeah so you'll go and find a
source that confirms whatever your
belief system and I'm guilty of it we go
even to the extreme yeah we're all
guilty of it we're all guilty you know
it's just like someone like pouchy is a
physician and a good person he's very
cautious Rand Paul saying the guy's a
very cautious deliver so yeah he's a and
it's very threatening to beat a turtle
and we're all assumed yeah and it's oh
so you're going to be if you you ever
notice how doctors sometimes are super
cautious - my son bumped his head one
time I don't know if I told you this and
he hit his head and he was a little boy
and the doctor said if I was my son I
would get I would get no I would get I
would get a some cat scan because they
show slice to the brain to make sure
he's okay and I we talk to it how that
did he hit in cushon specialty he hit it
like rocked it was hard but he was okay
but but then he looked in his eyes
everything's my son I would do because
it shows slice to the brain I was like
that's a huge thing and radiation I
talked to this other woman's a head
specialist I wouldn't do thoughts even
scarier son exactly it hit his head life
is life has its risks but this was a
very cautious man who's also remember
this if you see if you're a traffic
Bureau and insurance guys want your
doctor cautious by the way you want dr.
Carson's but if you if you are somebody
who is responsible Highway Safety and
you saw if you saw all the the [ __ ]
accidents you might be more inclined to
lower the speed limit to 40 miles an
hour cuz you know what would save life
well you know my father-in-law's
a shift Highway Patrol and when he
drives to me you know he's like he's
gotta slow down dude are you okay I'm
going 70 but he's a 65 yes no yes
thought oh my god and he sees he cuz he
and he sees the worst is the all the way
and let the bite the shocks all this
stuff all these things that this bike
makes the bike let it do its job these
are you're trying to control too much
you're too tense you know what I'm doing
as you're talking you're tense
mmm I'm threatening the horse people I
still haven't forgot all the horse
people I'm in town tomorrow
okay everybody shut your horse right now
if you say another word I thought so
[ __ ] when you tell these stories what
happens is I go into AI grows in my head
and then I get a snake of hatred in my
heart and then I I come up with revenge
scenario it was unbelievable
unbelievable
I got problems I I stopped think about
them literally when I went by I just
thought God people are stupid and then
kept going yeah and I was gonna be funny
story on the pot at least I got a story
on the podcast that's it man it's all an
opportunity it's a path to live like
that this too shall powers for them yeah
this too shall pass I just find myself I
will lick their horses and their faces
that's where I'm at in life and I get a
lot of I'm getting a lot of like DMS
from people going dude you're being a
response do your dams
no no listen III think masks are if I'm
around anybody old if I'm in a store if
that's what you want if I'm around
people have to be close people I wear a
mask I I'm all about it I understand I
I'm respectful did you see the thing I
love my car no big guys that we're
masking cars let me see so there are a
lot of funny masks out there to people
with bandanas I have a band down I feel
like a straight bank robber
that one right there who's that wear
face masks when they're driving hey
girls wow that's [ __ ] hilarious and
the most accurate meme the world has
ever known how many is that what the
[ __ ] is that impose the same thing and
go dudes that wear masks while they're
on the [ __ ] trails it's like Jesus
Christ dude Jesus guys what are you
gonna come in contact with
what are you watching me do that [ __ ]
scared of this look man if you are at
risk I'm gonna be respectful of you I'm
not saying not to wear a mask if you are
close to people I'm not saying social
I'm not a scientist I'm not saying
social distancing this I am a scientist
all of you guys know I am a scientist
and a doctor for that met dr. otologist
mm-hmm bike rider that's right listen if
you're not into bikes snakes and thick
dicks
then my profiles not for you no we can
see it though yeah you can look at it
right now that's all where the [ __ ] is
your mask
not crazy still thinking about that
can't do that to me because what happens
is it's in your head now I going to I'm
gonna cut this off it starts to fester
oh that's Brennan I'm that way he's that
way too but I'm I'm not like no I'm not
really that way you know you're not
something not with confrontation if we
have a business thing he'll go
I think we're getting [ __ ] here and
he'll just he'll just tells me that
actually I've seen you before
and then I I go ah what I trust you what
am I getting [ __ ]
and then I sleep on another thong and
then I'm I get I have an anger problem I
actually do when I get angry right away
you text right away you're like well let
me just yeah you have a bet you've been
angered yeah when I get angry it's it's
it's it's a problem yeah brother worse
yeah out of all my friends angers you
yeah you see Jay Jay if it's a big deal
he'll fly off the hinges yeah but you
I'll probably start punching way before
someone like that you would know
yeah even those people could have said
anything they wanted now if it's if it's
an injustice I get a little I get I
don't know something happens to me
people saw you almost getting a fight
outside here madam Alka oh yeah they're
like we would never seen Bryan like this
before yeah yeah I was gonna I was gonna
kill the guy
was that a bump right yeah he was but
he's young and he remembers you're like
a [ __ ] thing we'll be like you have
no money I made all the right choices
I'm gonna set you on fire
Bobo and then I then he yelled out it's
just cuz your dad and you were like I'm
gonna set you on fire yeah I said don't
set my fire yep and I said where's your
Matt was your [ __ ] mask and I trample
them with my horse
I said they trampled you with their
horse yeah horse was so big yeah this
horse giant that's 1,200 pounds of
muscle well you sure says I'm hungry I'm
gonna say I'm gonna find where where
your horse is and I'm gonna butcher it
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]